trente quatre listes en compétition pour
ces européennes
le nombre jamais vu ne renforce pas
forcément la passion des électeurs
malgré tout la machine démocratique est
en route et pour la préfecture il s'agit
de faire parvenir les professions de foi
à chaque électeurs martiniquais le 21
mai au plus tard
depuis hier mardi et jusqu'à dimanche
120 agents s'activent pour informer la
population dans les temps est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment d'aider un petit
peu la mobilisation des électeurs en
martinique a bien sûr là ce qu'on fait
c'est saïd et une petite piqûre de
rappel aussi pour ceux qui voudraient
oublier ou c'est une grosse piqûre de
rappel tous les mouvements et partis en
lice n'ont pas eu forcément les fonds
nécessaires pour financer l'impression
de ces professions de foi
ainsi les enveloppes qui vont vous être
envoyé non comporte que 22 sur les 34
les autres sont consultables sur
internet
je sais que vous obtenez des
préoccupations le nôtre qui n'a c'est
vrai qu'on n'est pas très très motivés
pour ce scrutin
mais c'est vrai qu'à travers ce qu'on
fait on peut éventuellement se stabilise
vous sentez que vous et vos collègues
vous êtes motivé la belle a vu la
cadence
l'organisation n'a pas de l'intérêt
privé sur veut aller au bout également
les premières enveloppes ont déjà été
distribués par la postière jusqu'à mardi
dernier délai il n'y en aura plus de 300
2000 le nombre d'inscrits à ce jour en
martinique